[Music]
in Noah thank you this not thank you not
thank you
no gracias not another did you no no
thank you in Chinese means you're
welcome
no yeah are you saying no they accuse it
[ __ ] it means yeah that means uh
means I don't even mention it how much
no thank you
and to say you're welcome - no thank you
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you confuse me
like that's almost as thank you and
there's a no thank you that means I do
don't even take me do tomorrow yeah yeah
yeah anyway submitted but I want it
don't touch my moustache oh no no for
you Japanese
don't touch my my moustache it oh that's
your logo my moustache that's not no
thank you
mmm submitted by bigger is better
not all way dude you don't like my you
know huge daughter
I bet it's huge dude have a nice calm
stop think what is dick you freaked I
just said I bet no I mean about
obviously no thing I haven't been bust
it's very oh yeah you like so writing
his dick so hard for yeah you Jorah
[ __ ] this number one finish it
fighting why do you bring me into this I
just say thank you yes wonderful you
should all go to the gym jabong that's a
little different
I'd be a compliment a guy like the
egging you got a great ass girl yeah
yeah it's not the deal the CEO burka
sucks explains why they turned down a
collab with superglue poop Birkenstock
your feet I said I brought mine
Jesus there's obviously something wrong
with you because dog those aren't the
ones that I know it's that's you know I
remember they were popular like in the
[ __ ] minute
they're only never stop no they stopped
they stopped they want to come back they
did some things I remember I used to
have a pair they should have done that
had a pair yeah they're comfortable s
really I know the category lace I just
think they look cool huh you know a
category those shoes go into my gina has
no sense of fashion she could be gold in
the 1-1 it's a same category as the
speakers at his toes are you put them in
crock no rock I own oh my god also what
else how shoes what are those
yes David once oh yeah
no you can't don't Gina don't put them
in there don't put Gina don't crooks I'm
just confused
don't use those shoes for the dads that
stand there and go yes wearing the
skedaddle like those are those shoes I
feel like I feel like you're like me
Bobby's with the beach bum shoes for me
yes they're really cool Shan the velcro
sandals and dads we're with Eva I love
you dad why certainly Bob you gotta be
the ones that wrap around the front
ankle yeah yeah
water shoes I love them every time I go
to Hawaii I always wear those yes
because they're dumb yeah cuz it's like
land and really comfy they look super
yeah they're know this [ __ ] actually
texted me when we were going to Vegas
I'll need a photo brush I was this close
buying you some burger your Earth Day
felt like I wanted to been a hunter
books like that she's gonna hate me in
like majesty you don't like how they
look
I [ __ ] hate them is that a brand or
is that the style to break bread
it's like tissue and Kleenex like it's
back in a day I didn't even know what
they were called
it was just leather shoes leather
sandals I bought some from Target so
they're not the brand Last Supper you
need those much I do think that they're
better than gone wrong props are way
more comfortable but Burks would look
better but they should have no supreme
deal either way yeah why did it turn
those a crane they said that photos
wouldn't wear those yeah they would
bright red eye were if they were supreme
irrevocably Wow concepts you will if
they're if they were bright red I'm not
a cop man
so this entire article can just be
boiled down to one sentence so there's a
book but the reason why they turned down
the supreme collab was because quote
there is no benefit for us except
prostitution what does that mean sorry
holding themselves out to supreme hurts
oh yeah yeah that's what why do they do
it like that I don't even know what that
means yeah precious ass [ __ ] yeah get
off your high horse [ __ ] you - [ __ ] you
collab yeah Louboutin a supreme art
tight hello [ __ ] sunny with very tiny
less Levi's North Face supreme they got
a Nike I think Arriba that's not I
understand what caused those because the
type of people that buy those shoes
they're probably like organic ass hippie
vegans that is pieces
I don't shared or managed so maybe they
got a stand by the customary supreme if
supreme hopped on them and they were
there like hotrod red Iraq them dude
they would make so much money
so they are saying no confidence so
that's your people love supreme bro
that's your pretentious as people know
second James Burke Burke's I'm Gigi no
thank you
pretentious as to Gio and their [ __ ]
burger Cyrus I have made the [ __ ]
company I think they look cool you can't
eat on me no I can't take [ __ ] really
back
oh yeah cuz I thought like clothing
companies were just like youtubers where
they like to come like combine forces
and like it benefits them to just like
do that there's what in this case maybe
there's some [ __ ] that we don't know
about supreme like maybe they're like
you are saying here that initially they
were interested but then I think man do
those mock-ups I saw the mock but then
that it didn't come to fruition because
of design
technicality but what they want is a
crazy that's it yeah that's a
pretentious I love you yeah that's just
how they do their just feel like holes
yeah why they would just open such a new
door for them but they got some likes
and they would have got some cool kids
where and I'm still you know strong
right now it's stupid all agree brands
have the street wear light now yeah so
whatever went down through that deal the
way that they saw it was this
opportunity is not worth it because it
would be like selling ourselves yeah
don't know if it was selective I would
like to know what that is I want to know
too because I've seen the mock-up it is
it's a hot rod read it says supremo so
they were conceptualizing it and then it
was being neat than in all that squeeze
right uh the ones I looked at had a
brown bottom but yeah that's what I saw
but this one looks like it's Photoshop
they're all or I think big mock-ups yeah
the girl face Oh cuz the other one looks
real er yeah yeah all right well it
looks like a crop that's why I don't
think I remember
oh no what I was in jail and I saw some
supreme like legit supreme [ __ ] and
selling it was a trip to me because I
would see supreme shirts and they didn't
even bother to take off like the Hanes
tag or Triple A or whatever the [ __ ] I
was like that's not that's a great
supreme is that they especially their
t-shirts and [ __ ] it's made on such
cheap face t-shirts but people still buy
it for the blondes there's my mother's
apron but that's that's their point no
but that is Street where culture where
it's like you know what you're buying
right you're not buying into the show
you're buying into the culture yes right
so they'll know up front say like yeah
we print on Triple A like that's not the
point it's it's that when you wear this
and you're going to another part of the
world and someone else is wearing it's
like you guys give a head nod like now
we're part of the same yeah but I wish
it was like Rolex where you do have
another Rolex buyer and you give
yourself a head nod because you know
y'all paid for that [ __ ] old [ __ ] you
don't mean like that that's like 2 grand
for payless shoes yeah whatever you know
like and then I go back and in like
y'all it's a little bit like that we got
the fake compliment like that because
like she said you know what you're going
into you know the culture and then
hopefully you know there fuk YouTube to
that and you're almost there almost anti
Rolex were like it's about all exterior
supreme Club yeah I think so it's almost
about like counterculture that's exactly
what it does I get it but people are
paying a lot of money to do this yeah
yeah so the funny thing is it's kind of
like this so like cuz you're paying the
people that are buying it they're paying
them they're not going for the value and
for the height exactly like no no I get
that I'm out I'm on the same page the
thing that I find very interesting is to
prove a point
people will spend lots of money it
sounds like the art world yes in the art
world right like modern art or whatever
like like I could [ __ ] scribble up
anything on it as a canvas yeah and say
this is $10,000 yeah and some people
will pay that just to make some type of
pretentious like argument or make it fun
but and that kind of Y supreme right now
is kind of outside of that street world
like if you talk to real street head
like Street where people they're like
well supreme is their own thing now
they're not really part of us anymore
yeah so so the funny thing is when I
made the the Rolex point it's kind of
like so to make fun of those guys you
guys are doing the same exact thing by
paying the same exact young to be a part
of this exclusive group yeah
right that's why I'm like but if you're
gonna do that anyway
why don't you get the real [ __ ] that's
also from our outsider yeah I see but
they have so much culture built within
street with yeah maybe I thought I just
don't get it here some of it too is like
is like like a head nod not only did you
get it but like a head not like your
whoa Claud you got that because it was
back in the day too though where it was
like you had to dig for this [ __ ] yeah
even now though too because you have to
be like the first [ __ ] clicking
or your spam grant but it means like my
fav I was only bucks yeah but if I had
to reset but I got a brand new yeah
pyresoul it'll be 500 bucks I buy some
supreme stuff because actually like the
red and white looks cool yeah it's cool
some people get so [ __ ] stupid with
it because it's because the be right
there yeah that's different rather like
the woods and dumb [ __ ] who bought the
brick you [ __ ] idiot what is wrong
with you or you're the culture it is I
got I'm like oh man I don't I don't
understand because I like value and the
things that I buy but people that buy
into the hype like there's a [ __ ]
like supreme battering ram
yeah a supreme like kids tricycle and
kinds of crazy [ __ ] that makes no sense
to the demographic but for them
exclusive if I let me take the ultimate
[ __ ] you to the world we're like we do
whatever the [ __ ] we want
so people buy into that people buy a
supreme ashtray even the little smoke
yeah I'm part of that cause I like
something I think something is what I
don't like is that people will buy
anything that says supreme on it like if
they don't even like the tea yeah now
I'm only gonna buy stuff that actually
like like I think I do think the bricks
funny or like I've thought about buying
an ashtray house a troll in part oh no I
like however they have an AK yeah they
make an axe it seemed like yeah I must
making a goddamn flamethrower yeah like
that's stupid too useful you know like a
big door no yeah oh [ __ ] yeah absolutely
but like I got like it's a dream duffel
bag that but sick it's a [ __ ] brick
dude what are you doing no Jess that's a
paperweight yeah it's for when the one
and a million people walk by they
recognize that break the goal you're so
right
and what was the other one vanity and
efficiency yeah this one's the vanity
things is stupid
[Music]